So what was it like after election day this week for the couple who live in the White House? Every morning, they got up, put on their robes, went downstairs, and jumped in the pool for a swim.
这周选举日过后，住在白宫里的那对夫妇生活如何呢？每天早晨，他们起床，披上睡袍，下楼，然后跳进泳池游个泳。
And we do that year round. And, of course, coffee is very mandatory. [LAUGHS]
我们一年四季都这样做。当然，咖啡是必不可少的。[笑声]
And then?
然后呢？
Well, the usual. I go fight with the face and Max Factor and my husband goes off to the office.
嗯，跟平时一样。我去和化妆品还有Max Factor（蜜丝佛陀）斗智斗勇，我丈夫就去办公室了。
The office in this case is not the Oval Office. No, she spends more time there. He drives into San Francisco where he has an office for his business in international finance. The couple who live in this house are named Norman Eckersley and Rosemary Ashley Eckersley. Neither is a member of the Democratic Party. Both have lots more money than the President of the United States. And the White House-- this one, anyway-- is about 15 miles south of San Francisco in a suburb called Hillsborough.
这里的办公室指的不是白宫椭圆形办公室。不，她在那里花的时间更多。他开车去旧金山，在那里他有自己的国际金融业务办公室。住在这栋房子里的夫妇名叫诺曼·埃克斯利和罗斯玛丽·阿什利·埃克斯利。他们都不是民主党成员。两人的钱都比美国总统多得多。而且这座白宫——至少这一座——位于旧金山以南约15英里处，在一个叫希尔斯伯勒的郊区。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, surprising stories of American politics. We have campaign diaries from Michael Lewis, a new theory of politics and television from Henry Jenkins, the Mexican-American self-deportation movement, Joan Jett Black, and we start with Act One, Life in the White House.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目将讲述关于美国政治的惊人故事。我们有迈克尔·刘易斯的竞选日记，亨利·詹金斯关于政治和电视的新理论，墨西哥裔美国人的“自我驱逐”运动，琼·杰特·布莱克的故事，我们首先从第一幕开始：《白宫生活》。
My tour guide at the Western White House-- this White House-- was the real estate agent who's trying to sell the thing, Ann Riley. And she began the tour with a packet of old photos and press clippings that she'd assembled.
我在“西部白宫”——也就是这座白宫——的导游，是负责出售这处房产的房地产经纪人安·莱利。她带着一叠自己整理的旧照片和剪报开始了参观导览。
This is really quite a fascinating home, and it has had several lives. It started off this.
这真是一栋非常迷人的住宅，它经历过好几次变迁。最初它是这样的。
Originally, this just looks like just a regular big old house.
起初，它看起来就像一栋普通的大旧房子。
It was a Victorian. It was an old Victorian. Here it is in the beginning.
它曾是维多利亚风格的。这是一栋古老的维多利亚式建筑。这是它刚建成时的样子。
The house has been around for over half the life of the United States. And it's the kind of huge structure that reflects every prevailing fashion over time. It's been redesigned in the neoclassical style, the French Normandy style, as a massive Swiss chalet, as a Mediterranean home with a tile roof.
这座房子已经存在了超过美国建国时间的一半。它是一种巨大的建筑结构，反映了各个时代的流行趋势。它曾被重新设计成新古典主义风格、法国诺曼底风格、巨大的瑞士木屋风格，以及带有瓦屋顶的地中海风格。
And finally, in 1930, George Hearst, the oldest son of newspaper magnate William Randolph Hearst, bought this place and hired Julia Morgan, the architect who designed Hearst's castle-- San Simeon-- to turn this house into a facsimile of the White House. Why? Ann Riley says the best guess anybody has is this.
最后，在1930年，报业大亨威廉·伦道夫·赫斯特的长子乔治·赫斯特买下了这个地方，并聘请了设计过赫斯特城堡（圣西蒙）的建筑师朱莉娅·摩根，将这栋房子改建成白宫的复制品。为什么？安·莱利说大家最合理的猜测是这样的。
Julia Morgan's charge was to deliver a house that he could invite the presidents to stay in when they came to the West Coast. So that's the myth. And I say it's a story.
朱莉娅·摩根的任务是交付一栋房子，让他在总统来到西海岸时可以邀请他们来住。所以这只是个传说。我说这只是个故事。
And we actually don't know exactly why he decided. There's no documentation or quotes or anything from him saying, "Here is why I'm going to do this."
其实我们并不确切知道他为什么这么决定。没有任何文件或引述说明他曾说过：“我之所以要这样做是因为……”
Well, his father, you know, had all these wonderful Hollywood starlets cavorting all over San Simeon. There was all this great stuff going on. And I think George was just trying to rise to the occasion. So what else would be famous besides a movie starlet? Well, the presidents of the United States might give him a little muscle in the family feud. It just feels so "mmm."
嗯，他的父亲你知道，在圣西蒙城堡里到处都是那些迷人的好莱坞小明星。那里发生了很多很棒的事情。我想乔治只是想迎合这种氛围。除了电影明星，还有什么会出名呢？嗯，美国总统可能会在家族纷争中给他撑腰。感觉就是那么回事。
And once your dad builds Hearst Castle, what are you going to do?
而且一旦你父亲建了赫斯特城堡，你还能做什么呢？
It's not an exact duplicate. Yes, there's an oval office. Yes, there's a rose garden. Yes, the columns in the window bays. the fireplace mantles, and the pediments above doors are modeled on those at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue. But it's more of a kind of tribute to the White House than a copy. From the outside, it reminds you of the White House the way that Madonna resembles Ava Peron. They're shooting for the same effect. There's a strong resemblance. But the copy just doesn't have the gravitas of the original.
它不是完全一样的复制品。是的，有一个椭圆形办公室。是的，有一个玫瑰园。是的，窗湾里的柱子、壁炉架和门上的三角楣饰都是仿照宾夕法尼亚大道1600号的那些设计的。但与其说是复制品，不如说它是对白宫的一种致敬。从外面看，它让人想起白宫的方式，就像麦当娜长得像艾娃·贝隆一样。它们追求的是同样的效果。有很强的相似性。但这个复制品就是没有原作的那种庄严感。
Now, this is a fun room. Upstairs play room. Painted bright red slashed with silver paint. Ping pong tables, exercise equipment, massage table.
这是一个很有趣的房间。楼上的游戏室。漆成鲜红色，点缀着银色油漆。有乒乓球桌、健身器材、按摩床。
And again, this is, like, a lacquer red room.
再说一次，这就像一个漆红色的房间。
Actually, this is a carpet that lights up. It has lights in it.
其实，这是一个会发光的地毯。它里面有灯。
What?
什么？
This carpet lights up. I don't know how to turn it on. But do you see all those little pinholes?
这个地毯会发光。我不知道怎么打开它。但你看到那些小针孔了吗？
Yeah.
看到了。
Those actually can be turned on.
那些其实是可以打开的。
The owners of this White House reflect the times just as clearly as the occupants of that other White House back East do. During the last century, they included one of the men who founded banks in California and financed the railroad's expansion through the West. And the owner of the shoe company that made Buster Browns. In 1972, it was rumored that John Lennon and Yoko Ono would be moving in.
这座白宫的主人们和东部那座白宫的住户一样，清晰地反映了时代的变迁。在上个世纪，他们包括了一位在加利福尼亚创建银行并为铁路向西部扩张提供资金的商人，以及制造“巴斯特·布朗”童鞋的公司老板。1972年，还有传言说约翰·列侬和小野洋子要搬进来。
As for the current owners, they made their money the way people do these days. He comes from the world of international banking, she from Hollywood. She was the wife of a studio vice president and the wife of a plastic surgeon before this marriage. When I meet her, she descends a staircase telling a slightly off-color and actually very funny joke. Before an hour's up, she's told me why Jean Harlow used to put ice on her breasts, why there are nude calendar girl paintings of herself over the beds in the house, and some story that Jane Russell told her the other night at dinner. I liked her.
至于现在的房主，他们像如今的人们一样积累了财富。他来自国际银行业，她来自好莱坞。在这次婚姻之前，她是某制片厂副总裁的妻子，也是一位整形外科医生的妻子。当我见到她时，她走下楼梯，讲了一个稍微有点荤但也确实非常有趣的笑话。不到一小时，她就告诉了我为什么珍·哈露过去常在胸部敷冰块，为什么房里的床上方挂着她本人的裸体日历女郎画，还有简·拉塞尔那天晚上在晚餐时告诉她的一些故事。我喜欢她。
You know the old song-- Cyndi Lauper-- "Girls Just Want to Have Fun." That's me. I think that if we can't enjoy our life-- and I tell my friends, I always have something. I have a big calendar on my desk. And I always have something that I can look forward to, even if I have to make that date. If I look down and say, well, I think I'll plan on going to Las Vegas this month. If I have to create something to make that month special, I do it.
你知道那首老歌——辛迪·劳帕尔的《女孩只想寻开心》。那就是我。我认为如果我们要享受生活——我告诉我的朋友们，我总是有目标。我的桌子上有一个大日历。我总有一些可以期待的事情，即使我必须自己去安排那个日期。如果我往下看，心想，嗯，我计划这个月去拉斯维加斯。如果我必须创造一些东西来让那个月变得特别，我会去做的。
The house itself is a mix of high-brow and low-brow-- incredibly elegant rooms with beautiful furniture and expensive paintings, and here and there, paintings of doe-eyed girls, picked up at sidewalk art sales. The little embroidered pillows that say things like, "Murder, yes. Divorce, never" And "Screw the golden years, there's a safari room." In short, it's hard to imagine Bill Clinton living here. But it's a place that his mother-- Virginia Kelley-- would probably just love.
房子本身是高雅与低俗的混合体——有极其优雅的房间、漂亮的家具和昂贵的画作，但也随处可见在路边艺术品摊上买来的那种瞪着大眼睛的女郎画。绣着诸如“谋杀可以，离婚不行”和“去它的黄金岁月，有个狩猎屋”之类的可爱小枕头。简而言之，很难想象比尔·克林顿会住在这里。但这是一个他的母亲——弗吉尼亚·凯利——很可能会喜欢的地方。
It is impossible to imagine an American building a house today as a duplicate of the White House as a way to lure the president over. People just do not view the presidency with the same respect as they did back in George Hearst's day. Witness Rosemary's response when I ask her this question about her home purchase.
很难想象今天还会有人为了引诱总统过来而建造一座白宫复制品。人们对总统职位的尊重程度已经不像乔治·赫斯特时代那样了。看看当我问罗斯玛丽关于她购房的问题时她的反应就知道了。
Was the fact that it was, in part, a replica of the White House part of what drew you to it?
这栋房子在某种程度上是白宫的复制品，这一点是你被它吸引的原因之一吗？
No, it wasn't. It really wasn't.
不，不是。真的不是。
The asking price for this Western White House is $8.5 million. It has 27,000 square feet, 22 rooms. Coldwell Banker real estate agents recently put together an estimate of what the real White House would sell for if it were ever put on the open market. The real White House, by the way, has 43,000 square feet and 132 rooms. It sits on 18 acres of prime downtown real estate.
这座“西部白宫”的要价是850万美元。它有27000平方英尺，22个房间。科威银行的房地产经纪人最近估算了一下，如果真正的白宫进入公开市场，它会卖多少钱。顺便说一下，真正的白宫有43000平方英尺，132个房间。它坐落在市中心18英亩的黄金地段。
Estimate? $64 million. Actually, to qualify for the mortgage, you'd have to be able to make monthly payments $600,000 a month. $64 million. Of course, according to the FEC, candidates Clinton and Dole each spent far more than that for the privilege of just living in the place for four years.
估价是多少？6400万美元。实际上，要获得抵押贷款资格，你每月需要支付60万美元的月供。6400万美元。当然，根据联邦选举委员会的说法，克林顿和多尔候选人为了仅仅能在那地方住上四年的特权，花费的钱远不止这些。
Act Two, Television Man. Throughout this election year, we've been bringing you the campaign diaries of Michael Lewis. He's been publishing these in The New Republic . And as I've said many times in introducing him, they are among the most surprising and interesting campaign reporting that anyone has done this year.
第二幕：《电视人》。在整个竞选年里，我们一直在为你带来迈克尔·刘易斯的竞选日记。他一直在《新共和》杂志上发表这些文章。正如我多次介绍他时所说，这是今年任何人所做的最令人惊讶和有趣的竞选报道。
Michael Lewis has said in the past that one of the reasons for the dullness and mendacity in modern campaigns is that American politicians still have not adjusted to the presence of television cameras. He got a chance to see the effect of television cameras firsthand on the political process just last month when he momentarily left the unglamorous life of a print reporter for another higher calling.
迈克尔·刘易斯过去曾说，现代竞选活动枯燥和谎话连篇的原因之一是，美国政治家们仍然没有适应电视摄像机的存在。上个月，当他暂时离开印刷媒体记者的平淡生活，转而追求一项更崇高的使命时，他亲眼目睹了电视摄像机对政治进程的影响。
October 1. The Dole campaign treats me so oddly when I arrive this morning for the trip to Cleveland that I find myself looking back over my shoulder to see if there's some other Michael they're talking to. That I have a name is itself unusual. Normally, I'm just checked off the cargo list as The New Republic i.e., another magazine writer who, together with his readership, can safely be ignored. But this morning, I am carrying my new Sony Digital Super SteadyShot Handycam DCR-VX1000 millimeter, a palmable grey box that crack technicians from ABC spent nearly an hour teaching me to use. It is festooned with various stickers that say ABC News.
10月1日。今天早上我到达克利夫兰参加行程时，多尔竞选团队对我态度非常古怪，以至于我不得不回头看看他们是不是在和别的什么迈克尔说话。我有名字这件事本身就很不寻常。通常我只是被当作货物清单上的“《新共和》杂志”一栏，即另一个可以被安然无视的杂志撰稿人。但今天早上，我带着我的索尼数码摄像机DCR-VX1000，这是一个可以放在掌心的灰色盒子，ABC的专业技术人员花了近一个小时教我使用。它上面贴满了各种写着“ABC新闻”的贴纸。
Yesterday, I mentioned in passing to a Dole staffer that I might do some shooting for Nightline tomorrow, as if I were the sort of person who did shooting for Nightline all the time. Now, a Dole campaign worker named Charlie is standing over me like an old friend. "Hi, Michael," he says. "Good to see you again. You know, you're not allowed to film on the plane."
昨天，我顺便向一名多尔竞选团队的工作人员提到，我明天可能会为《夜线》拍摄一些素材，就像我是一个经常为《夜线》拍摄的人一样。现在，一个叫查理的多尔竞选工作人员像老朋友一样站在我身边。“嗨，迈克尔，”他说。“很高兴再次见到你。你知道，飞机上是不允许拍摄的。”
When I step onto the plane, a second Dole staffer tells me the same thing. As I take my seat across the coffee table from a radio lady, a third Dole worker stops by and stresses the point. Apparently, the place where the campaign television journalist spends the vast majority of his time is considered outside the bounds of television journalism.
当我踏上飞机时，第二个多尔团队人员也对我说了同样的话。当我坐在咖啡桌对面一个电台女记者旁边时，第三个多尔员工走过来再次强调了这一点。显然，竞选电视记者花费绝大部分时间的地方，被认为是在电视新闻报道范围之外。
Before all these warnings, it had never occurred to me to film on the Dole plane. Now it does. Just before takeoff, I stand up and take my first shot. A fat cameraman on his way to the toilet squeezes past a skinny stewardess, and I have him in my crosshairs. "You're not supposed to do that!" a voice shrieks out at me. It's the radio lady playing narc. Charlie appears beside my seat to remind me of "the rule." He does a nice job of not being upset.
在所有这些警告之前，我从未想过要在多尔的飞机上拍摄。现在我想了。起飞前，我站起来拍了第一张镜头。一个胖摄影师在去洗手间的路上挤过一个瘦瘦的空姐，我把镜头对准了他。“你不准这样做！”一个声音向我尖叫。是那个扮演告密者的电台女士。查理出现在我的座位旁提醒我“规则”。他没表现出生气，做得不错。
The day unfolds uneventfully-- Dole gives a speech in a gym-- except for my peculiar new relationship with the Dole campaign staff. Normally, I have to set off a flare to get their attention. Today, Charlie takes the seat beside me on the bus and for the rest of the day never seems to be very far away. Whatever they think I might do, I don't. By the time the rally starts, I have busted the sound mechanism, lost the earplugs, and run out of batteries. I put the camera to one side. Charlie vanishes.
这一天过得很平淡——多尔在健身房发表了演讲——除了我和多尔竞选团队之间这种奇特的新关系。通常我得发射照明弹才能引起他们的注意。今天，查理坐在了公交车我旁边的座位上，而且剩下的时间里似乎从未离我很远。不管他们认为我会做什么，我都没有做。当集会开始时，我已经弄坏了声音装置，弄丢了耳塞，电池也用完了。我把摄像机放在了一边。查理也消失了。
But then we head back to the plane and a fresh battery, which brings us to the episode of the shrimp.
但随后我们回到飞机上换了新电池，这就引出了“虾”的插曲。
Once we'd settled into our seats, I set about trying to fix all the parts of the camera I'd busted. In order not to offend the Dole people, I decide to test the thing on what I figure is a declassified object-- a large plate of cold, mottled shrimp that has been laid on the table between me and a pair of radio reporters.
一旦我们在座位上坐好，我就开始着手修理我弄坏的摄像机零件。为了不冒犯多尔的人，我决定用我认为是解密的对象来测试它——一张大盘子里装着冷掉的、斑驳的虾，就放在我和两个电台记者之间的桌子上。
I hunker right over the little buggers so that the ABC technicians will see I have absorbed what they've taught me about not giving in to the temptation of zoom. But the moment I'm in place, the radio woman shrieks out to the Dole staff and makes to cover the shrimp with a sheet of paper. "It's OK," I say gently. "I'm just seeing if this thing still works." I keep shooting for a good five seconds. Then I put the camera away.
我直接蹲在那几个小东西上方，这样ABC的技术人员就会看到我已经领会了他们教我的关于不要屈服于变焦诱惑的教诲。但就在我准备好的一瞬间，那个电台女记者向多尔团队尖叫起来，并试图用一张纸盖住那些虾。“没关系，”我温和地说。“我只是看看这东西还能不能用。”我继续拍摄了五秒钟。然后我收起了摄像机。
Suddenly, a Dole lady is in my face, teeth gritted, breath blowing. "We told you seven times not to film on the plane," she shouts. "You don't know how serious this is."
突然，一名多尔团队的女士冲到我面前，咬牙切齿，呼吸急促。“我们告诉过你七次不要在飞机上拍摄，”她喊道。“你根本不知道这有多严重。”
"But it was just the shrimp," I begin to say before she cuts me off. "We told you." I want to protest that it's not my fault her guy is 20 points down the polls, and she's on the fast track to not being the next Dee Dee Myers. It's not worth the trouble.
“但那只是些虾而已，”我刚开口就被她打断了。“我们告诉过你了。”我本想抗议说，她老板在民调中落后20个百分点又不是我的错，而且她也正处于当不了下一个迪·迪·迈尔斯的快车道上。但这不值得费劲。
I return to the New York Times where Dole's campaign manager, Scott Reed, is quoted as saying that some major event is about to transform public opinion. "We deserve a break, and we're going to have one," he explains. Asked to be more specific, he said, "Something. World affairs." It's hard to see how the shrimp fit into this scenario.
我回到《纽约时报》的报道上，多尔的竞选经理斯科特·里德在报道中称，一些重大事件即将改变公众舆论。“我们值得休息一下，我们会有的，”他解释说。当被要求更具体一点时，他说，“某种东西。世界事务。”很难看出虾和这个剧本有什么关系。
October 6. On the streets outside the debate hall in Hartford, the Super SteadyShot wreaks havoc. Many hundreds of previously listless protesters leap into action at the sight of it. "Let's have some action for ABC," I shout. And the effect is distinctly more dramatic than if I'd said, "Let's have some action for The New Republic ."
10月6日。在哈特福德辩论大厅外的街道上，那台数码摄像机造成了混乱。许多数百名原本无精打采的抗议者一看到它就跳了起来。“让ABC看点精彩的，”我喊道。效果明显比我喊“让《新共和》看点精彩的”要强烈得多。
They rise as one and proclaim their causes. One moment, they are an undifferentiated jumble of people shivering in the cold. The next, they are the ardent supporters of Nader and Perot, pro-life and anti-vivisection, anti-deficit and pro-welfare. Of course, the SteadyShot is not permitted inside the Bushnell Theatre. It is too powerful a weapon to be permitted close to the candidates.
他们齐声站起来宣扬他们的事业。片刻之前，他们还是一群在寒风中颤抖的乌合之众。下一刻，他们就成了纳德和佩罗的狂热支持者，或是拥护生命权反对活体解剖，或是反对赤字支持福利政策的人。当然，这台摄像机是不被允许带入布什内尔剧院的。它是太强大的武器，不能让它靠近候选人。
So after a brief altercation with a security guard, I retire to Spin Alley. Spin Alley is what the debate organizers have renamed the Hartford Civic Center until a few journalists start pointing out that only a few years ago, political hacks actually denied that they "spun" at all. The signs saying Spin Alley are then ripped down, which, when you think about it, is itself a form of spin.
所以，在与保安发生短暂争执后，我退到了“旋转巷”。旋转巷是辩论组织者给哈特福德市民中心改的名字，直到几名记者指出，就在几年前，政治黑客们还在否认他们“旋转”任何事情。写着“旋转巷”的牌子随后被拆除，想想看，这本身也是一种旋转。
At any rate, the Super SteadyShot penetrates Spin Alley, emanating its extraordinary forcefield. When she enters the frame, the comely Maureen Dowd dives behind her notepad, and who can blame her? Once you're in the camera's eye, you no longer have control of your soul. Truly, it is astonishing the way all of the important people cave in to the camera.
无论如何，那台摄像机渗透进了旋转巷，散发出非凡的力场。当她进入画面时，漂亮的莫琳·多德躲在笔记本后面，谁能怪她呢？一旦你进入镜头，你就失去了对灵魂的控制。确实，所有重要人物向镜头妥协的方式令人震惊。
I point it at White House Spokesman Mike McCurry, then at Pennsylvania Governor Tom Ridge, then at Labor Secretary Robert Reich. They answer questions that they might ignore if it were just me and mine eye. How do you feel as you stand there spinning me? If you truly felt that your candidate had lost, would you say as much?
我把它对准白宫发言人迈克·麦柯里，然后是宾夕法尼亚州州长汤姆·里奇，再然后是劳工部长罗伯特·赖克。他们回答的问题如果只是面对我和我的眼睛，他们可能会忽略掉。当你站在那里对我进行旋转操作时，你感觉如何？如果你真的觉得你的候选人输了，你会承认吗？
They are not talking to me, of course, but to some notional audience-- the American people. And whatever they might be thinking, they treat the camera with deference. In the same way that ordinary people feel obliged to smile when they have their picture taken-- even when they are unhappy-- important people feel pressure to answer sincerely even when they are insincere.
他们当然不是在对我说话，而是对某种观念上的观众——美国人民。无论他们心里在想什么，他们都对镜头表现出尊重。就像普通人在拍照时感到有义务微笑——即使他们并不开心——重要人物在回答时即使并不真诚，也感到必须表现得真诚。
I miss the debate entirely. I'm too busy taking pictures of people assessing the debate, which they do from the moment it starts. No matter. I'm able to track its effect between the lines of Scott Reed's quotes. Tomorrow in the New York Times , Reed will revise his mental picture of the campaign. "This is going to be a steady building process for the next 30 days," he will say. "There's not going to be an overnight shift." All of a sudden, it's looking as if every little shrimp might matter.
我完全错过了辩论。我忙于拍摄那些评估辩论的人，他们从辩论一开始就在评估。没关系。我能在斯科特·里德的话语行间追踪到它的影响。明天在《纽约时报》上，里德将修正他对竞选的心理图像。“这将是一个未来30天稳步建立的过程，”他会说。“不会有一夜之间的转变。”突然间，看起来好像每一只小虾都可能很重要。
Michael Lewis' campaign diaries will be collected in a book called Losers: Real Men Don't Become President Anymore. Stay with us, now. We will have another set of campaign diaries from Michael Lewis later in the program.
迈克尔·刘易斯的竞选日记将被收录在一本名为《失败者：真正的人不再成为总统》的书里。现在留在这里。节目稍后我们会有迈克尔·刘易斯的另一组竞选日记。
This section of our program on television continues. We have this argument about TV and politics from Henry Jenkins, director of film and media studies at MIT.
我们节目关于电视的这一部分继续进行。我们有来自麻省理工学院电影与媒体研究主任亨利·詹金斯的关于电视和政治的论点。
I think what we're dealing with is a kind of crucial transitional moment in American politics. And it's actually change that's occurred over the last couple of elections from an era where network television dominated the political campaign toward a point where cable television is dominating the campaign and looking toward a point when cyberspace or the online communities will dominate. Each of those medium have different properties which candidates have to respond to and shape their campaigns around.
我认为我们正在处理的是美国政治中一种关键的转型时刻。这实际上是在过去几届选举中发生的变化，从网络电视主导政治竞选的时代，转向有线电视主导竞选的节点，并展望未来网络空间或在线社区将主导的时刻。每种媒介都有不同的属性，候选人必须对这些属性做出回应，并围绕它们塑造他们的竞选活动。
So if we go back eight years to Bush versus Dukakis, Bush was a paramount politician of an era of network television. Network is based on a broadcast model. That is, it speaks the same message to multiple publics. There's not a lot of targeting to regional-specific audiences or narrow demographic groups.
所以如果我们回到八年前布什对决杜卡基斯的时代，布什是网络电视时代的卓越政治家。网络基于广播模型。也就是说，它向多个公众传播相同的信息。并没有针对特定地区受众或狭窄人口群体进行太多的定向投放。
The strategy that Bush adapted in that campaign is what he called "Story of the Day." "Story of the Day" is you pick a topic that you want to hit your opponent on especially, and you find ways to dramatize that topic through images, through your personal appearances, through the other people who are tied to the campaign who are giving talking points. And you want one unified message which carries the day.
布什在竞选中采取的策略是他所谓的“每日故事”。“每日故事”就是你选择一个你想用来打击对手的主题，并找到方法通过图像、你的公开露面、以及与竞选挂钩的其他通过谈话要点传达的人来戏剧化这个主题。你需要一个统一的信息，来赢得当天的关注。
Classic example is Bush goes to Boston Harbor to attack to Dukakis on his environmental record. All three major news networks gave that top coverage that evening. And what you find is that news cameras use the same soundbites by Bush, they use the same images, the cameras actually do Bush's dirty work by focusing directly on the sewage waste in the Boston Harbor and dramatizing his issues. And Dukakis' response is simply him talking to the camera. So that's the politics of the network era.
典型的例子是布什去波士顿港攻击杜卡基斯的环保记录。当晚所有三家主要新闻网络都对此进行了顶级报道。你会发现新闻摄像机使用了布什同样的录音片段，使用了同样的图像，摄像机实际上通过直接聚焦于波士顿港的污水废物并戏剧化他的议题，完成了布什的肮脏工作。而杜卡基的回应只是他对着镜头说话。这就是网络时代的政治。
Four years pass, and the way America watches television changes fairly drastically over that period of time. More and more people are getting their news and information from cable. There's a wider array of options. And cable is embracing this narrowcasting notion of specific appeals to specific demographic groups, of targeted messages, of a focused public. And Clinton recognizes that there are all kinds of opportunities in cable that were not there in the network broadcast paradigm.
四年过去了，美国人观看电视的方式在那段时间发生了相当剧烈的变化。越来越多的人从有线电视中获取新闻和信息。选择范围更广了。有线电视拥抱了这种针对特定人口群体的窄播概念，即定向信息，聚焦的公众。克林顿认识到有线电视中存在着网络广播范式中所没有的各种机会。
So Clinton uses cable to completely blindside Bush. He goes on MTV. He goes on Arsenio Hall. He goes on Larry King. He goes on Nashville Network. He's courting a number of different publics with different messages that are tailored very intensely to the interest of that particular group. What appears on network TV is simply an image of that appearance-- Clinton answering questions about his underwear on MTV or Clinton playing the saxophone on Arsenio Hall, often images that trivialize those appearances. But for the constituencies that Clinton is speaking to, such as the MTV audience, he's given an enormous amount of space to frame his issues and his terms to that specific voting block.
所以克林顿利用有线电视完全奇袭了布什。他上了MTV。他上了阿塞尼奥·霍尔秀。他上了拉里·金直播室。他上了纳什维尔网络。他正在针对特定群体的兴趣，以极度量身定制的信息向不同的公众求爱。在网络电视上出现的只是那次露面的影像——克林顿在MTV上回答关于他内衣的问题，或者在阿塞尼奥·霍尔秀上吹萨克斯风，这些影像往往贬低了那些露面的意义。但对于克林顿正在交谈的选民群体，比如MTV观众，他获得了巨大的空间来框定他的议题和针对那个特定投票区的条款。
So what we get is a diffused message from Clinton during that campaign, which motivates voters. So the largest voter participation of 18- to 27-year-olds of any election in recent memory-- since the 18-year-olds got the right to vote, in fact-- motivated by Clinton's appearance on MTV. And Rock the Vote was really pivotal in bringing out that election.
所以我们得到的是克林顿在竞选期间传播的信息，这激励了选民。所以这是最近记忆中选民参与度最高的一次——在18至27岁的人群中，事实上是自18岁获得投票权以来——受克林顿在MTV上的露面激励。而“摇滚投票”组织在调动选民方面确实起了关键作用。
And so what have you seen this year in the '96 campaign? How has this developed this year?
那么你今年在96年的竞选中看到了什么？今年它是如何发展的？
Well, Clinton, I think, learned a brutalizing message, which is that you run on cable right now but you have to govern on network TV. That is, all those diffused messages to multiple publics, which developed intense voter participation four years ago, became scattershot, confused, decentered unfocused when he tried to govern because he was still being evaluated on those three major networks on the evening news. And in that space, Clinton's administration seemed completely incompetent. So Clinton had to retool himself for the evening news.
嗯，我想克林顿学到了一个残酷的教训，那就是你现在可以在有线电视上竞选，但你必须在网络电视上执政。也就是说，他四年前对多个公众传播的那些分散信息，虽然激发了强烈的选民参与度，但他尝试执政时却变得零散、混乱、去中心化且没有焦点，因为他仍然在三大网络晚间新闻上接受评估。在那个空间里，克林顿的政府显得完全无能。所以克林顿不得不为晚间新闻重新调整自己。
The same message was learned by Newt Gingrich, who is also a product of cable television. And I like to call Gingrich and Clinton the "not ready for prime time players" because they were, in fact, such products of cable that they weren't ready for prime time network news. Gingrich's career begins on C-SPAN. And what Gingrich did as a young representative from a small district in Georgia was realize there was a slot in the day in the early evening hours which historically had been used by representatives to stand up in an empty house and deliver messages which went directly to Congressional Record and were sent out to constituents back home.
纽特·金里奇也学到了同样的教训，他也是有线电视的产品。我喜欢称金里奇和克林顿为“不适合黄金时段的选手”，因为他们实际上是有线电视的产品，所以他们还没有准备好应对黄金时段的网络新闻。金里奇的职业生涯始于C-SPAN。作为佐治亚州一个小选区的年轻议员，金里奇意识到在傍晚时分有一个空档，历史上议员们曾利用这个时间站在空荡荡的众议院发表直接进入国会记录并发送给家乡选民的信息。
Gingrich recognized that that was free air time on C-SPAN every evening in the dinner hour. He went on every night at the same time, the same focused speech on every issue of the day, and said flamboyant things that had a very intense appeal to conservative Americans. He graduated from that to The Family Network and to GOP TV, which are even more focused on the conservative constituencies. And he was able to spring from free air time on C-SPAN to a national political constituency.
金里奇认识到那是C-SPAN每天晚餐时间免费的播出时间。他每晚在同一时间上线，对当天的每个议题进行同样的聚焦演讲，并发表了吸引美国保守派的煽动性言论。他从那里毕业，进入了家庭电视网和共和党电视网，这些电视网更加关注保守派选民。他能够从C-SPAN的免费播出时间跃升为全国性的政治选民群体。
The minute he reaches power, though, he's also being judged by the evening news where those red meat issues that he focused, that got attention on C-SPAN, suddenly seem too intense or too conservative or too reactionary and extreme for middle America. And so he also failed to be able to govern on network television. So we're seeing is that politicians are being pulled back and forth between the network paradigm of a general message to a general audience and the cable space which opens up a lot of chances for challengers to emerge and to begin to exploit the medium to get messages out and motivate very intensely committed groups of voters.
然而，他一获得权力，也受到了晚间新闻的评判，那些他在C-SPAN上关注的强硬议题，突然间对美国中产阶级来说显得太激烈、太保守、太反动或太极端。所以他也未能实现在网络电视上执政。所以我们看到的是，政治家们正在网络范式（针对一般受众的一般信息）和有线空间（为挑战者提供大量机会出现并开始利用媒体传播信息并激励极其忠诚的选民群体）之间来回拉扯。
Have you seen either candidate actually use the cable strategy in this election?
你是否看到有候选人在这次选举中真正使用了有线电视策略？
I think Clinton still uses it, but I don't think either of them are using it as effectively as Clinton did four years ago. I think they are frightened by it. Dole is fairly inept at every medium I can think of. There's not a single medium one could say Bob Dole uses well. We've seen him completely misunderstand the nature of this cable politics in the last debate, where he's used to talking on network news, where he talks over the interviewer and delivers his message no matter what.
我想克林顿仍然在使用它，但我不认为他们两人有任何一个像四年前克林顿那样有效地使用它。我想他们被它吓到了。多尔在我能想到的每种媒介上都相当笨拙。没有一种媒介可以说鲍勃·多尔用得好。我们在上一次辩论中看到他完全误解了这种有线电视政治的本质，他习惯在网络新闻上说话，在那里他盖过采访者，不管怎样都要传达他的信息。
That very first question in the debate when the school teacher asked him about children's innocence and their hopes for the future, and he used it in cynically as a platform to attack Bill Clinton on his ethics issue. One saw an example where he didn't understand the embodiment of those issues in specific people and specific constituencies and how it matters who you're speaking to and where you're speaking in cable.
辩论中那个第一个问题，当学校老师问他关于孩子的天真和他们对未来的希望时，他愤世嫉俗地把它当作一个攻击比尔·克林顿道德议题的平台。人们看到一个例子，他不理解这些议题在特定人群和特定选民群体中的体现，以及你在有线电视中和谁说话、在哪里说话有多重要。
I asked Henry Jenkins if he wasn't overstating his thesis a little, especially when it came to Bill Clinton. I wondered if Bill Clinton didn't know more about handling the network news when he took office than Jenkins gives him credit for. After all, in 1992, Bill Clinton made four or five cable appearances during the campaign. But he wasn't just running on cable. Every day of the campaign, there were staged events for the network news and there was the Clinton message of the day.
我问亨利·詹金斯，他是否在夸大他的论点，特别是在比尔·克林顿时。我想知道当克林顿上任时，他是否比詹金斯给予他的评价更懂得如何处理网络新闻。毕竟，在1992年，比尔·克林顿在竞选期间进行了四五次有线电视露面。但他不仅仅是在有线电视上竞选。竞选的每一天，都有为网络新闻策划的活动，还有克林顿每日的信息。
But those are moments that are probably the most memorable moments in the campaign. They are moments they were replayed over and over on those networks. They are moments that I think shaped public perceptions of these candidates in a significant way. And I think our understanding of Clinton was defined more through those moments than through the evening news. So their impact is much greater than the sheer number of events.
但那些时刻可能是竞选过程中最令人难忘的时刻。它们是在这些网络上被反复播放的时刻。它们是我认为以重要方式塑造了公众对这些候选人感知的时刻。我认为我们对比尔·克林顿的理解更多是通过那些时刻，而不是晚间新闻。所以它们的影响远大于活动数量本身。
Henry Jenkins is director of film and media studies at MIT and author of two books. The latest is called Science Fiction Adventures: Watching Star Trek and Doctor Who .
亨利·詹金斯是麻省理工学院电影与媒体研究主任，也是两本书的作者。最新的一本名为《科幻冒险：观看星际迷航和神秘博士》。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and invite a wide range of writers and performers and documentary producers to contribute stories on that theme. Today's theme, of course, Post-Election Politics. We're at Act Three of our program, Losers. In this act, we have a story of an unsuccessful presidential candidate, and this story of a struggling political movement.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们节目每周当然都会选择一个主题，邀请广泛的作家、表演者和纪录片制作人贡献关于该主题的故事。今天的主题当然是“选后政治”。我们到了我们节目的第三幕，《失败者》。在这一幕中，我们有一个关于失败的总统候选人的故事，和一个关于陷入困境的政治运动的故事。
Hey, Pedro. Go back to Mexico, stop taking our jobs, and stop looking at my daughter!
嘿，佩德罗。滚回墨西哥去，别再抢我们的工作，也别再盯着我女儿看了！
Immigrants, are you tired of being pushed around in America? Well, don't sit on your serape. Do something about it. Join the conservative political action group HALTO-- Hispanics Against Liberal Takeover.
移民们，你们厌倦了在美国被欺负吗？好吧，别坐在你们的披肩上了。做点什么吧。加入保守派政治行动组织HALTO——反对自由派接管的西班牙裔。
HALTO was formed by Mexicali karaoke lounge sensation Daniel D. Portado as a way to spread California Governor Pete Wilson's message of self-deportation to a national audience.
HALTO是由墨西卡利卡拉OK酒廊轰动人物丹尼尔·D·波塔多组建的，旨在将加州州长皮特·威尔逊的“自我驱逐”信息传播给全国受众。
I am the chairman of HALTO, Daniel D. Portado. What is self-deportation, you ask? Think of it as a permanent vacation. Just imagine, in one easy step, you can avoid all this crazy anti-immigrant harassment in America. How? Self-deportation. Just imagine yourself on the beach, in Mazatlan, relaxed, tension-free. Immigrants, join HALTO today and see your homeland tomorrow.
我是HALTO的主席，丹尼尔·D·波塔多。你问什么是自我驱逐？把它想成一个永久假期。想象一下，只需简单一步，你就可以避免在美国所有这种疯狂的反移民骚扰。怎么做？自我驱逐。想象你自己正躺在马萨特兰的海滩上，放松，没有压力。移民们，今天加入HALTO，明天就看到你的祖国。
Self-deportation is a trademark of Hispanics Against Liberal Takeover. Subject agrees to voluntarily repatriate to native land or Mexico, whichever is nearest. All self-deportations are final. No exchanges or refunds. Tickets are one way only.
自我驱逐是“反对自由派接管的西班牙裔”的商标。受试者同意自愿遣返回祖国或墨西哥，以最近者为准。所有自我驱逐均不可撤销。不退不换。票仅限单程。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Well, listeners to our program in California may be familiar with this advertisement and with the group Hispanics Against Liberal Takeover. They are a militant self-deportation movement encouraging all minorities to leave the United States. That's right, all minorities. Its founder, Daniel D. Portado, has appeared on Spanish-language TV. I actually saw a video of one of these appearances where basically, the entire Latino studio audience yelled at him nonstop for his entire appearance.
嗯，我们加州的节目听众可能熟悉这则广告以及“反对自由派接管的西班牙裔”这个组织。他们是一个倡导所有少数族裔离开美国的激进自我驱逐运动。没错，是所有少数族裔。其创始人丹尼尔·D·波塔多曾在西班牙语电视上露面。我实际上看过其中一次露面的视频，基本上，整个拉丁裔演播室观众在他出现的整个过程中都在不停地对他大吼大叫。
Mr. Portado says that he started his movement when he read newspaper accounts about Mexican-Americans who were in favor of California's Proposition 187. Prop 187 was the proposition that cut off social services to illegal immigrants. He thought these Mexican-Americans-- who were in favor of cutting off those services-- had the right idea but just did not go far enough. They just didn't take it to its logical conclusion, and he felt that self-deportation was the only real solution.
波塔多先生说，他在阅读了关于支持加州187号提案的墨西哥裔美国人的报纸报道后开始了这项运动。187号提案是切断非法移民社会福利的提案。他认为这些支持削减这些福利的墨西哥裔美国人——想法是对的，只是走得还不够远。他们只是没有将其推向逻辑终点，他觉得自我驱逐才是唯一的真正解决方案。
We feel that the immigrants are taking too many jobs, are bringing down the quality of life. They're not allowing our young American teenagers the character-building experiences of picking fruit and cleaning hotel beds.
我们觉得移民抢了太多的工作，降低了生活质量。他们不让我们的美国青少年体验采摘水果和打扫旅馆床铺带来的性格塑造经历。
So what's your evaluation of this week's election results? Were the election results in California good or bad for your self-deportation movement?
那么你对本周选举结果的评估是什么？加州的选举结果对你的自我驱逐运动是有利还是不利？
Oh, well, luckily, Pete Wilson is still with us. Of course, I was the chairman, originally, of Hispanics for Wilson, the pro-187 group.
哦，嗯，幸运的是，皮特·威尔逊还和我们在一起。当然，我最初是“西班牙裔支持威尔逊”组织的主席，那是一个支持187号提案的团体。
Proposition 187 was the California proposition that suggested-- and passed-- saying that illegal immigrants could not receive any social services.
187号提案是加州的那个提案，它建议——并且通过了——说非法移民不能获得任何社会服务。
Right, right. And we are also sponsoring for the next election our own initiative, the "Spic and Span Initiative," which stands for Stop Promoting Illegal Culture and Spanish. Basically, we're trying to prohibit any sort of activity which might attract illegals to this country, such as dancing the Macarena, that would now be punishable by four Saturdays of freeway cleanup and a $250 fine.
对，对。而且我们正在为下一次选举赞助我们自己的倡议，“干净利落倡议”，它代表“停止推广非法文化和西班牙语”。基本上，我们试图禁止任何可能吸引非法移民来这个国家的活动，比如跳玛卡莲娜舞，那现在将受到惩罚，包括四个周六清理高速公路和250美元罚款。
Pretty steep.
挺严厉的。
And also saying certain words-- or any word-- in Spanish, such as Los Angeles, California, San Diego--
还有说某些词——或任何词——用西班牙语，比如洛杉矶、加利福尼亚、圣迭戈——
Burrito.
墨西哥卷饼。
Burrito, yes. And churrito. You know, all these traditional-- things like Linda Ronstadt records will now be banned.
墨西哥卷饼，是的。还有墨西哥油条。你知道，所有这些传统的——诸如琳达·朗丝黛的唱片之类的东西现在都将被禁止。
Those ones where she sings the Mexican songs?
就是她唱墨西哥歌曲的那种？
Yes, the ones that she doesn't understand what she's singing. But it's very harmful. And it's like a yodel out to the immigrants. It's saying, "Are you out there? Is there anyone out there? Would you like to come to America?" That's what, basically, Linda Ronstadt is saying.
是的，那种她自己都不明白自己在唱什么的歌曲。但这非常有害。这就像是对移民的一种约德尔唱法。它在说，“你们在外面吗？外面有人吗？你们想来美国吗？”这就是琳达·朗丝黛基本上在说的话。
When she sings a Spanish-language song, you mean she is pulling people across the border with the power of her voice?
当她唱西班牙语歌曲时，你的意思是她正在用歌声的力量把人们拉过边境？
Yes, it is a major conspiracy. You did not know. Governor Wilson has discovered that there is a major conspiracy to get all sorts of Indios from remote villages to come over. I mean, when Clinton says it takes a village, he's talking about importing a whole village from Michoacan. Don't you know that?
是的，这是一个巨大的阴谋。你不知道吧。威尔逊州长发现有一个巨大的阴谋，要把来自偏远村庄的各种印第安人弄过来。我的意思是，当克林顿说“需要一个村庄”时，他谈论的是从米却肯进口整个村庄。你不知道吗？
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Also, we have discovered, with the help of Governor Wilson, that the Macarena is actually a very sinister mind control device. And it is part of a conspiracy to control the white electorate's feeble mind.
此外，在威尔逊州长的帮助下，我们发现玛卡莲娜实际上是一个非常邪恶的思维控制装置。它是控制白人选民脆弱头脑的阴谋的一部分。
What do you mean? How do you figure? What is it doing to the white electorate?
什么意思？你怎么看出来的？它对白人选民做了什么？
Well, we actually have a translation here by our researchers that we can read for you.
嗯，我们的研究人员这里实际上有一个翻译，我们可以为你读一下。
All right, sure. These are the words to the Macarena?
好的，当然。这是玛卡莲娜的歌词？
Yes.
是的。
Sure.
当然。
So my bodyguard, Rudy Rico, will do the translation in English and I will read the original lyrics in the soon-to-be-forbidden Spanish tongue. So here we go. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
所以我的保镖，鲁迪·里科，将用英语进行翻译，我将用很快就要被禁止的西班牙语舌尖读出原文歌词。那么我们开始吧。[说西班牙语]
I control your mind and body, gringo.
我控制你的思想和身体，老外（gringo）。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Now it's time to pick the fruit and make me rich.
现在是采摘水果并让我致富的时候了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Give me the keys to your Volvo, gringo.
把你的沃尔沃钥匙交出来，老外。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Hey, stupid gringo.
嘿，愚蠢的老外。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
See how foolish you look?
看你看起来有多傻？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
When you twist and dance to my mind control music.
当你随着我的思维控制音乐扭动和跳舞时。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Screw the police.
去死吧，警察。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Now go cook some food for my friends.
现在去为我的朋友煮点食物。
Macarena, macarena, macarena.
玛卡莲娜，玛卡莲娜，玛卡莲娜。
Stupid gringo, stupid gringo, stupid gringo.
愚蠢的老外，愚蠢的老外，愚蠢的老外。
So as you can see, this is a very sinister device.
所以正如你所见，这是一个非常邪恶的装置。
Let's go to other election results here. In California this week, voters voted on something called the California Civil Rights Initiative-- Proposition 209-- which was essentially a proposition to end quotas, set asides, and contracts. Basically, it was an anti-affirmative action measure. The fact that Californians voted for this anti-affirmative action measure this week, do you view that as being a positive thing for your movement?
让我们看看这里的其他选举结果。本周在加州，选民对所谓的“加州民权倡议”——209号提案——进行了投票，这本质上是一项结束配额、预留和合同的提案。基本上，它是一项反平权措施。加州人本周投票赞成这项反平权措施，你认为这对你们的运动来说是积极的事情吗？
Oh yes, I think it will allow these young Latinos and black youth to go back to their roots and traditions of picking fruit and parking cars in Hollywood. I think it's a very positive development for them. They need character building too. And if we can't deport them, well, we should employ them.
哦是的，我认为这将允许这些年轻的拉丁裔和黑人青年回到他们采摘水果和在好莱坞停车的根源和传统。我认为这对他们来说是一个非常积极的发展。他们也需要性格塑造。如果我们不能驱逐他们，好吧，我们应该雇用他们。
Daniel D. Portado, if you actually believe in deportation, what are you, yourself, still doing in California?
丹尼尔·D·波塔多，如果你真的相信驱逐，你本人还在加州做什么？
Well, I am here to help everyone get out. I hope to look forward to the day where I will stand at the border and say, will the last Mexican out of California please turn out the lights? That will be me.
嗯，我在这里是为了帮助每个人离开。我希望能盼望到那一天，我会站在边境说，最后一个离开加州的墨西哥人请关灯好吗？那个人将是我。
Let me ask you to just look ahead past this election that we just had towards the future. What is next for the self-deportation movement and for HALTO, for Hispanics Against Liberal Takeover?
让我请你展望一下这次刚刚结束的选举之后的未来。自我驱逐运动和HALTO（反对自由派接管的西班牙裔）接下来会发生什么？
Let me say this here first for you, Mr. Ira Glass, that I will now announce my candidacy for the California senate seat in 1998.
先让我为你在这里说一下，艾拉·格拉斯先生，我将宣布我竞选1998年加州参议院席位。
You have a slogan yet for that campaign?
你还没为那场竞选想出竞选口号吗？
Yes, we do have a slogan for that. The campaign is, "three Macarenas and you're out."
是的，我们确实有一个口号。竞选口号是：“三次玛卡莲娜，你就出局。”
[LAUGHS] Now, I understand that you have brought in a song that you want to perform for us.
[笑声] 那么，我听说你带了一首歌，想为我们表演。
Yes, this is an old chestnut sung to the tune of "New York, New York." I like to call it "Pedro, Pedro."
是的，这是一个老套路，唱的是《纽约，纽约》的曲调。我喜欢称它为《佩德罗，佩德罗》。
"Pedro, Pedro." And you're doing this, I understand, karaoke-style, out there.
《佩德罗，佩德罗》。我听说你在外面是用卡拉OK风格唱的。
Yes.
是的。
All right.
好的。
[SINGING] Start spreading the news. You're leaving today. You're going back to Mexico Pedro, Pedro. Start packing your bags, your Chevrolet too. You're going back to Mexico Pedro, Pedro. You little welfare monkey, take your cousin junkie and pack your trunkie and go. You're going away--
[唱歌] 开始传播消息。你今天就要离开。你要回墨西哥了，佩德罗，佩德罗。开始打包你的行李，还有你的雪佛兰。你要回墨西哥了，佩德罗，佩德罗。你这个小福利猴子，带上你的瘾君子表亲和你的破行李箱走吧。你要离开这里——
All across the country, losing politicians are licking their wounds and planning for tomorrow. And one presidential contender who did not win this year's general election is Joan Jett Black. Joan Jett Black first ran for mayor of Chicago in 1990 and this year, ran for president in drag. In a tasteful Chanel suit, Joan Jett Black gave speeches, made appearances, and lost. But she has not conceded despite President Clinton's overwhelming showing at the polls and vows she will fight on.
全国各地，失败的政客们都在舔舐伤口并为明天做打算。而今年大选未能获胜的一位总统竞选者是琼·杰特·布莱克。琼·杰特·布莱克在1990年首次竞选芝加哥市长，今年则穿着变装竞选总统。她穿着得体的香奈儿套装，发表演讲、公开露面，然后输了。但尽管克林顿总统在投票中以压倒性优势获胜，她仍未认输，并誓言将继续斗争。
There's a couple things. I'm still speaking. I've got a couple university things to go do in the near future. And I'm kind of like a community spokesmodel out here in San Francisco. And then I've also thought of starting the QRA-- the Queer Rifle Association.
有几件事。我还在继续演讲。在不久的将来，我还有几所大学的活动要参加。我是旧金山这里的一名社区代言人。然后我还想成立QRA——酷儿步枪协会。
I didn't realize your feelings about the Second Amendment were so strong. Why would that be necessary?
我没意识到你对宪法第二修正案的感情如此强烈。为什么要这样做呢？
Well, you know, because we can't get married, we barely can get housing, we barely can get jobs, so--
嗯，你知道，因为我们不能结婚，我们几乎住不上房子，我们几乎找不到工作，所以——
At least we can buy a gun?
至少我们可以买把枪？
We'll just start shooting. Yes. But I'm not saying shooting bullets. I mean, we could shoot water or something. I don't know.
我们就开始射击。是的。但我不是说射子弹。我是说，我们可以射水之类的。我不知道。
That is true, isn't it? I hadn't stopped to think about that. Gays can't get married, but they can buy a gun.
那是真的，不是吗？我还没停下来想过这个问题。同性恋者不能结婚，但他们可以买枪。
Yeah, and you know what the motto of the QRA will be, don't you?
是啊，你知道QRA的座右铭是什么吗？
No, I don't.
不，我不知道。
"What did you call me?" So there's that as well.
“你刚才叫我什么？” 所以还有这个。
You going to be out kissing babies and stuff between now and then?
在此期间你会出去亲吻婴儿什么的吗？
Well, I kiss babes. I'm not really fond of babies. But I kiss babes, yeah.
嗯，我亲吻宝贝（babes）。我不太喜欢婴儿。但我亲吻宝贝，是的。
Now, you make a lot of a public appearances and you meet a lot of politicians. You know a lot of politicians. You do a lot of public speaking. And I know that one of the things that you've said in the past I'd like you to explain a little bit is that you believe that a life in politics-- a politician's life-- is a great deal like a life in drag.
现在，你有很多公开露面，你也见过很多政治家。你认识很多政治家。你做了很多公开演讲。我知道你过去说过的一句话，我想让你解释一下，那就是你相信政治生活——政客的生活——非常像变装生活。
Well, it's very interesting that one of the things that they tell a presidential candidate is that you have to look presidential. You have to walk presidential. You have to move presidential. They put on the drag of being the president or the drag of being the governor or the drag of being senator.
嗯，非常有趣的是，他们告诉总统候选人的事情之一是，你必须看起来像总统。你必须走起来像总统。你必须动起来像总统。他们穿上了成为总统的变装，或是成为州长的变装，或是成为参议员的变装。
And it's very similar. In a way, it's acting. It's very similar to what drag is all about. And every little boy who wants to be president, he pictures himself standing in front of a podium speaking to a lot of people. And every little boy who wants to be a drag queen pictures himself standing in front of a microphone lip syncing to a lot of people. So it's almost the same thing to me.
这非常相似。在某种程度上，这是一种表演。它与变装的内容非常相似。每个想成为总统的小男孩，他都想象自己站在讲台前对很多人讲话。每个想成为变装皇后的小男孩，都想象自己站在麦克风前对很多人进行对口型表演。所以对我来说这几乎是一回事。
Joan Jett Black, presidential candidate for the year 2000.
琼·杰特·布莱克，2000年总统候选人。
Act Four, Inspiration. It is easy to feel dispirited by the way things went this election year. So we wanted to end our post-election show today with a story of some politics that would inspire us and not depress us, which brought us to this story. It was written in May by Michael Lewis. It's from his campaign diaries.
第四幕：《灵感》。在这个选举年，人们很容易对事情的发展感到沮丧。所以我们今天想用一个政治故事来结束我们的选后节目，这个故事会激励我们，而不是让我们沮丧，这把我们引向了这个故事。它是由迈克尔·刘易斯在五月写的。来自他的竞选日记。
April 19. I leave my hotel earlier than I need to and walk down from the Washington Monument to the Vietnam Veterans Memorial. Even at 7:30 in the morning, the Mall is nearly deserted, the Lincoln Memorial empty. The Vietnam Veterans Memorial, on the other hand, is teeming with people who appear to have been up for hours, walking slowly along the length of the black marble slab bearing the names of the dead. For the next 20 minutes, I sit on a bench dodging bird droppings and waiting for Senator John McCain, who has agreed to meet me here.
4月19日。我比计划提前出门，从华盛顿纪念碑走到越南战争退伍军人纪念碑。即使在早上7:30，广场也几乎空无一人，林肯纪念堂空空如也。另一方面，越南战争退伍军人纪念碑上挤满了人，他们似乎已经起床好几个小时了，缓慢地沿着刻着死者名字的黑色大理石板走着。接下来的20分钟里，我坐在长椅上避开鸟粪，等待同意在这里见我的参议员约翰·麦凯恩。
In my attempts to spot him at a distance, I can't help but notice how differently ordinary people behave from politicians. Maybe 50 likely candidates pass through my line of vision, and not one of them could pass for a US senator at 100 paces. They comb their hair in public, scratch themselves, hold hands.
在试图远距离寻找他时，我不禁注意到普通人的行为与政客的行为有多么不同。也许有50个潜在的候选人经过我的视野，没有一个人能在100步之外被误认为是美国参议员。他们在公共场合梳头、抓挠自己、牵手。
At 8:00 on the button, McCain appears at my side, looking very senatorial except for a pair of outrageously wide black aviator sunglasses with some undignified name-- Hobby? Hippo?-- stenciled on the earpiece. McCain is the Dole surrogate most in demand as a speaker around the country. And it's not hard to see why. What matters most to the people who wish to see McCain speak for Dole is the formative experience that the two senators ostensibly share. Both nearly died in a war. Both endured indescribable pain and suffering.
8点整，麦凯恩出现在我身边，看起来非常具有参议员风度，除了戴着一副极其宽大的黑色飞行员太阳镜，镜腿上印着一些不庄重的名字——霍比？河马？。麦凯恩是全国各地需求量最大的多尔代理演讲人。原因不难理解。对于那些希望看到麦凯恩为多尔演讲的人来说，最重要的是两位参议员表面上共有的塑造性经历。两人都曾在战争中差点死去。两人都忍受了难以言表的痛苦和折磨。
Dole's ordeal is at the center of his national campaign. To some extent, it is his campaign. McCain's trials are less known. On October 26, 1967, when he ejected out of his Navy jet and into a North Vietnamese mob, McCain suffered two broken arms, a shattered knee and shoulder, and bayonet wounds in his ankle and groin.
多尔的考验是他全国竞选的核心。在某种程度上，这就是他的竞选。麦凯恩的考验则鲜为人知。1967年10月26日，当他从海军喷气式飞机弹射进入北越暴徒群中时，麦凯恩两只手臂骨折，膝盖和肩膀粉碎，脚踝和腹股沟有刺刀伤。
Robert Timberg's gripping book, The Nightingale's Song, depicts McCain two months later in his first prison cell. McCain weighed less than 100 pounds. His hair, flecked with gray since high school, was nearly snow white. Clots of food clung to his face, neck, hair and beard. His cheeks were sunken, his neck chicken-like, his legs atrophying.
罗伯特·廷伯格的引人入胜的著作《夜莺之歌》描绘了两个月后麦凯恩在他第一个牢房里的样子。麦凯恩体重不到100磅。他的头发，自高中以来就夹杂着灰色，几乎变成了雪白色。食物结块粘在他的脸、脖子、头发和胡须上。他的脸颊凹陷，脖子像鸡脖子，腿部萎缩。
McCain survived in captivity without medical treatment for the next five years, enduring torture so exquisite that even to read about it causes sweat to pop out on your brow. His captors would hang him by his broken arms from dangling ropes for hours on end, for instance. But the astonishing part of McCain's experience was its voluntary aspect.
麦凯恩在接下来的五年里没有接受任何医疗救治而在囚禁中幸存下来，忍受着极其精妙的折磨，即使阅读有关内容也会让你额头上冒出汗水。例如，他的俘虏会把他用断臂挂在绳子上几个小时。但麦凯恩经历中最令人震惊的部分是它的自愿性。
McCain is the third generation of a distinguished military family. His father was an admiral during the Vietnam War. The North Vietnamese hoped that this famous prisoner of war would violate US military policy, which dictated that prisoners be returned in the order they arrived. If he accepted their offer of freedom, McCain would testify to the demoralization of the American troops. For five and a half years, his captors tried to torture him into going home. For five and a half years, he refused to go.
麦凯恩是著名军事家族的第三代。他的父亲是越战期间的一名海军上将。北越希望这位著名的战俘能违反美军政策，该政策规定战俘应按到达顺序遣返。如果他接受他们提供的自由，麦凯恩将证明美军的士气低落。五年半的时间里，他的俘虏试图通过折磨让他回家。五年半的时间里，他拒绝离开。
We walk alongside the black granite slab against the oncoming traffic, then back again. The Park Service says that the memorial has become the second most frequently visited site in Washington after the Capitol. McCain admits that at first, he found it depressing and even faintly antagonistic. But one day, he was passing through on his own-- he visits often by himself-- and discovered a couple of veterans running their hands across the inscribed names. Clearly, the two men had never met before, but they had fallen into conversation, swapped war stories, and in a few minutes were clutching each other and weeping. If that kind of healing goes on, says McCain, well, then it's a good thing.
我们逆着人流沿着黑色花岗岩板走，然后又走回来。公园管理局表示，这座纪念碑已经成为华盛顿仅次于国会大厦的第二大访问量最大的地点。麦凯恩承认，起初他觉得它令人沮丧，甚至有轻微的敌意。但有一天，他独自经过——他经常独自去——发现几个退伍军人在刻有名字的石板上摸索。显然，这两个人以前从未见过面，但他们陷入了交谈，交流了战争故事，几分钟之内就抱头痛哭。如果这种治愈方式还在进行，麦凯恩说，好吧，那这是一件好事。
Someone once said that an explanation is where the mind comes to rest. There is a feeling about McCain-- one that seems lacking in Dole-- that he has somehow explained his own experience to himself. He has assimilated his trauma differently than the candidate he's behind. He says, "This is the McCain theory, and I think it's valid. I was an adult when I was shot down. 31 years old. I'd had a whole life. He was 19. What were you like when you were 19? I believe that everything Bob Dole has done since the war was dictated by that experience."
有人曾说，解释是思想得到安息的地方。关于麦凯恩有一种感觉——多尔似乎缺乏这种感觉——他已经以某种方式向自己解释了自己的经历。他比他支持的候选人以不同的方式消化了自己的创伤。他说，“这是麦凯恩理论，我认为它是有效的。我被击落时是一个成年人。31岁。我经历了一整个人生。他当时19岁。你19岁时是什么样子？我相信鲍勃·多尔战后所做的一切都是由那次经历决定的。”
The Vietnam veteran has achieved a kind of equanimity that is supposed to be reserved only for veterans of good wars. When Clinton arrived at the White House, for instance, McCain sent him a note saying that any time the president wished to walk down to the Vietnam Veterans Memorial, the senator from Arizona would be glad to walk alongside him. Clinton sent back a nice note. Recalling this exchange causes McCain to break his rhythm. We were walking back towards the bench, and McCain is limping slightly, like a high school football star. Hi is remembering something else.
这位越战老兵获得了一种通常只属于好战争老兵的平静。例如，当克林顿到达白宫时，麦凯恩给他写了一张纸条，说只要总统愿意走到越南战争退伍军人纪念碑，来自亚利桑那州的参议员很乐意陪他走过去。克林顿回了一张漂亮的纸条。回想起这次交流，麦凯恩打乱了他的节奏。我们正走回长椅，麦凯恩稍微有点跛，就像高中足球明星一样。他想起了别的事。
"I don't know if you want to write about this," he begins. "Back in the mid-'80s, a guy who protested the war came into my office. He said his name was David Ifshin."
“我不知道你是否想写这个，”他开始说。“回到80年代中期，一个抗议战争的人来到我的办公室。他说他叫大卫·伊夫申。”
In December 1970, David Ifshin had led a group of American students to Hanoi, where he delivered an antiwar radio address to American soldiers engaged in attacks on North Vietnam. Like other anti-American propaganda, his program was piped into McCain's prison cell from 6:00 in the morning until 9:00 at night. But McCain, who can generate anger in a heartbeat, shows not the faintest trace of resentment. He explains, "Ifshin stood in my office and he says, 'I came here to tell you I made a mistake. I was wrong, and I'm sorry.' And I said to him, 'Look, I accept your apology. We'll be friends. But more importantly, I want you to forget it. Go on with your life. You cannot look back.'"
1970年12月，大卫·伊夫申带领一群美国学生去了河内，在那里他对参与袭击北越的美国士兵发表了反战广播演讲。像其他反美宣传一样，他的节目从早上6点到晚上9点通过管道传进麦凯恩的牢房。但麦凯恩，这个能在瞬间产生愤怒的人，却没有表现出丝毫的怨恨。他解释说，“伊夫申站在我的办公室里说，‘我来这里是为了告诉你我犯了一个错误。我错了，我很抱歉。’ 我对他说，‘看，我接受你的道歉。我们会成为朋友。但更重要的是，我希望你忘了它。继续你的生活。你不能回头看。’”
Here he pauses, and I figure he's finished. But he's groping behind his aviator sunglasses for the point of his anecdote, that forgiveness is ultimately less self-destructive than the bitter desire for revenge. Or perhaps that there is no such thing as revenge. Five months ago, David Ifshin was diagnosed with cancer. The cancer has proved untreatable and has spread rapidly. David Ifshin is now dying. He's 47 years old and has a wife and three young children. Says McCain, "When I heard about it, it did pass through my mind. Suppose I had told David Ifshin to get the hell out of my office. How would I feel about myself now?"
他在这里停顿了一下，我以为他讲完了。但他正在他的飞行员太阳镜后面搜寻他轶事的重点，即宽恕最终比仇恨的复仇欲望破坏性更小。或者也许根本没有复仇这回事。五个月前，大卫·伊夫申被诊断出患有癌症。癌症被证明无法治愈，并且迅速扩散。大卫·伊夫申现在正在死去。他47岁，有妻子和三个年幼的孩子。麦凯恩说，“当我听到这个消息时，它确实闪过我的脑海。假设我曾告诉大卫·伊夫申滚出我的办公室。我现在会怎么看自己？”
April 23. I'm walking out the door of my Washington apartment on my way to find David Ifshin when John McCain calls. I've made the mistake of telling his press secretary what I'm up to, and she's passed it along to the senator, who is seriously concerned. He says, "Look, I don't mean to insult you, but be careful with this. If you wrote anything that hurt David or Gail or the kids, I'd never forgive myself. I'd forgive you, but I wouldn't forgive myself."
4月23日。我正走出华盛顿公寓的门准备去找大卫·伊夫申，这时约翰·麦凯恩打电话来。我犯了一个错误，告诉了他的新闻秘书我要去干什么，她把它传给了参议员，他非常担心。他说，“看，我不是要侮辱你，但这件事要小心。如果你写的任何东西伤害了大卫或盖尔或孩子们，我永远不会原谅自己。我会原谅你，但我不会原谅自己。”
It's a half-hour drive out of Washington to the Ifshin's house in the Maryland suburbs, where I find a gaunt, bearded man stretched out on a patio lounge chair, attended by his wife, Gail. This afternoon he's tired, and his voice is barely audible as he sketches his political career. The cover of Life magazine of April 23, 1971 shows David Ifshin, age 22, at a war rally, wearing a collegiate goatee. He's standing directly behind Jane Fonda, who has her fist raised. After his war protests, he worked on a kibbutz.
开车半小时离开华盛顿来到马里兰郊区的伊夫申家，在那里我发现一个枯瘦、留着胡子的男人躺在露台的躺椅上，由他的妻子盖尔照顾。今天下午他很累，当他描绘他的政治生涯时，声音微弱到几乎听不见。《生活》杂志4月23日1971期的封面上显示了大卫·伊夫申，22岁，在一个战争集会上，留着大学生的山羊胡。他正站在简·方达身后，她挥舞着拳头。反战后，他在基布兹工作过。
But when he returned to America, he also returned to national politics. He went on to work on the Mondale campaign and, to a storm of protest, was even tapped to head the Dukakis transition team. He spent 10 years as general counsel to AIPAC, the Israeli lobby. He had met Clinton briefly in 1972. 20 years later, when Clinton ran for president, Ifshin became general counsel for his campaign. Before he accepted the job, however, he told Clinton he'd been attacked for his war record each time he'd joined a presidential campaign.
但当他回到美国时，他也回到了全国政治中。他后来在蒙代尔竞选团队工作，甚至在一片抗议声中被选为杜卡基斯过渡团队的负责人。他担任了10年美国以色列公共事务委员会（AIPAC）的法律总顾问。他曾在1972年短暂见过克林顿。20年后，当克林顿竞选总统时，伊夫申成为他竞选活动的法律总顾问。然而，在他接受这份工作之前，他告诉克林顿，他每次加入总统竞选团队时都会因为他的战争记录受到攻击。
He says, "I brought it up with Clinton deliberately. And he said he knew what I'd done, and he admired it then. And that he still admired it now."
他说，“我故意把这件事向克林顿提了出来。他说他知道我做过什么，而且他当时很钦佩。他说他现在仍然钦佩。”
These days, Clinton calls Ifshin two or three times each week, even when he's traveling. A few months ago, the Ifshin family spent the night in the Lincoln bedroom. In the pictures of Clinton playing with the Ifshin children, the president's ruddy good health seems almost obscene besides Ifshin's drawn face. Yet, when I called him, David Ifshin did not hesitate to rise to the occasion. He says, "I'm very proud of this story, and it's never been written," I ask him about his feelings towards McCain. He says, "One of our true political heroes. He's a giant."
这些天，克林顿每周给伊夫申打两三次电话，即使在他旅行时也是如此。几个月前，伊夫申一家在林肯卧室住了一晚。在克林顿和伊夫申孩子们玩耍的照片中，总统红润健康的肤色在伊夫申那张消瘦的脸旁显得近乎猥琐。然而，当我打电话给他时，大卫·伊夫申毫不犹豫地挺身而出。他说，“我很为这个故事感到自豪，而且它从未被写过，”我问他对麦凯恩的感受。他说，“我们真正的政治英雄之一。他是个巨人。”
Ifshin's version of their story differs from McCain's in its important details and in its spirit. The way McCain tells it, Ifshin is the hero. He decided he'd made a mistake and bravely took responsibility for his actions. The way Ifshin tells it, McCain is the hero. As I listened to him, I realized that this is the reverse of the usual Washington investigation in which the reporter visits each interested party to collect the dirt on the adversary. Here is a case where each is needed to explain the other's nobility of spirit. I have never heard two political allies-- much less two political opponents-- cast each other in a more flattering light.
伊夫申讲述的故事版本在重要细节和精神上与麦凯恩的不同。按照麦凯恩的说法，伊夫申是英雄。他决定自己犯了一个错误，并勇敢地为自己的行为负责。按照伊夫申的说法，麦凯恩是英雄。当我听他讲时，我意识到这与通常的华盛顿调查正好相反，在调查中记者访问每一位相关方以收集对手的脏水。这是一个各方都需要解释对方精神高尚的案例。我从未听说过两个政治盟友——更不用说两个政治对手——把对方描写得如此光辉。
Ifshin begins, "I had always wanted to apologize, but didn't know who to apologize to." His moment to act, he decided, came at an AIPAC meeting around 1986 at the Washington Hilton. Ifshin spotted Senator John McCain at a distance and decided that he was the man who deserved the apology. Ifshin says, "I hoisted up my courage and went over to him. And before I could get a word out, McCain says, 'I owe you an apology.'"
伊夫申开始说，“我一直想道歉，但不知道该向谁道歉。”他决定采取行动的时刻，发生在大约1986年在华盛顿希尔顿酒店举行的AIPAC会议上。伊夫申从远处发现了参议员约翰·麦凯恩，并认定他就是那个应该接受道歉的人。伊夫申说，“我鼓起勇气走到他面前。我还没开口，麦凯恩就说，‘我欠你一个道歉。’”
A couple of years earlier, during the 1984 presidential campaign, McCain had given a speech in which he attacked Ifshin's war record. "Basically, someone had handed him a script," says Ifshin, "and he read it. He was sorry he did it, and said he wouldn't do that kind of thing again. Then he asked me to stop by his office, which I did, and normally wouldn't do. It was blind fate, I told him at that time. I said, 'I owed you an apology, and you robbed me of the chance to make it.' And he was characteristically modest and humble about it." Later that year, McCain and Ifshin, together with a Vietnamese emigre named Doan Van Toai, established the Institute for Democracy in Vietnam.
几年以前，在1984年总统竞选期间，麦凯恩曾发表过演讲，攻击伊夫申的战争记录。“基本上，有人递给他一个剧本，”伊夫申说，“他就读了。他很后悔这么做，并说他不会再做那种事了。然后他请我顺便去他的办公室，我就去了，通常我是不会去的。那是宿命，我当时对他说了。我说，‘我欠你一个道歉，而你剥夺了我道歉的机会。’ 他当时表现得非常谦虚和谦逊。”那年晚些时候，麦凯恩和伊夫申，连同一个叫段文蔡的越南移民，成立了越南民主学院。
Ifshin shifts painfully in his chair and stops to catch his breath. It was at the Vietnam Veterans Memorial that what he calls "the second half of the story" with McCain began. On Memorial Day of 1993, Bill Clinton spoke at the site. Both McCain and Ifshin were present. Clinton was cheered loudly. He was also heckled. And one of the hecklers waved a sign that said "tell us about Ifshin."
伊夫申痛苦地在椅子上挪动了一下，停下来喘口气。就是在越南战争退伍军人纪念碑，他所说的与麦凯恩“故事的下半部分”开始了。在1993年的阵亡将士纪念日，比尔·克林顿在现场发表了演讲。麦凯恩和伊夫申都在场。克林顿受到了热烈的欢呼。他也受到了嘲讽。其中一个嘲讽者挥舞着一块写着“告诉我们关于伊夫申的事”的牌子。
Four weeks later, Ifshin found himself on a flight to Washington with McCain, who motioned for him to take the seat beside him. Ifshin says, "He asked why I hadn't taken a job in the administration. I said this and that. We played 20 questions until finally he said, 'It's because of that stupid sign, isn't it?' And I said, "Yes, partly it was.' And he said, 'Come to my office tomorrow morning and we'll settle this thing once and for all.'"
四个星期后，伊夫申发现自己和麦凯恩在一架飞往华盛顿的航班上，麦凯恩示意让他坐在他身边。伊夫申说，“他问我为什么没在政府里找工作。我说这啊那啊。我们玩了20个问题，最后他说，‘是因为那块愚蠢的牌子，对吧？’ 我说，‘是的，部分原因是。’ 他说，‘明天早上来我办公室，我们一次性把这件事解决掉。’”
The next day, June 30, 1993, David Ifshin turned up in John McCain's office in the Russell Senate Office Building to find that the senator had drafted a letter which he entered later that day in the Congressional Record . It began by praising Clinton's Memorial Day address on behalf of Vietnam's veterans. The veterans, McCain wrote, "were very impressed by Clinton's determination to offer an eloquent tribute to their service when it would have been far easier for him to avoid the event altogether. McCain decried the behavior of the protesters. Then he moved on.
第二天，1993年6月30日，大卫·伊夫申出现在约翰·麦凯恩在罗素参议院办公楼的办公室，发现参议员已经起草了一封信，当天晚些时候他将其录入《国会记录》。它首先赞扬了克林顿代表越战老兵发表的阵亡将士纪念日演讲。麦凯恩写道，退伍军人们“对比尔·克林顿决定为他们的服务提供雄辩的致敬感到印象深刻，尽管对他来说完全避开这次活动要容易得多。麦凯恩谴责了抗议者的行为。然后他继续说。
"Among the demonstrators that day, one individual held a sign which asked the president to explain his association with a person known to many of our colleagues, Mr. David Ifshin. 'Tell us about Ifshin,' it read. My other purpose in speaking today is to do just that. I want to talk about David Ifshin. David Ifshin is my friend. This declaration may come as a shock to those people whose perception of David--"
“在那天的抗议者中，一个人举着一块牌子，要求总统解释他与许多同事熟知的一位人士——大卫·伊夫申先生——的关系。‘告诉我们关于伊夫申的事，’上面写着。我今天发言的另一个目的是正是为了做这件事。我想谈谈大卫·伊夫申。大卫·伊夫申是我的朋友。这个声明可能会让那些对大卫认知为——的人感到震惊。”
Well, in the weeks after that was published-- it was published in May, by the way, not written in May-- David Ifshin died, and John McCain became a leading vice presidential contender after Jack Kemp. It was John McCain who nominated Bob Dole, gave the speech for that at the Republican National Convention. And Michael Lewis ran into McCain on Election Day.
嗯，在那之后发表的几周里——顺便说一下，那是在五月发表的，而不是五月写的——大卫·伊夫申去世了，约翰·麦凯恩成为杰克·肯普之后的主要副总统竞争者。正是约翰·麦凯恩提名了鲍勃·多尔，并在共和党全国代表大会上为此发表了演讲。迈克尔·刘易斯在选举日遇到了麦凯恩。
It was funny. Everywhere you went with the Dole campaign, senators and governors would come out of the woodwork because they wanted to have their picture taken and show support, all the rest. Until the final day, and they all cleared out. No senators or governors were traveling with him. There was one person at his side, and it was John McCain.
这很有趣。无论你跟多尔竞选团队去哪里，参议员和州长都会出现，因为他们想拍照并表示支持，等等。直到最后一天，他们都撤走了。没有参议员或州长随他同行。他身边只有一个人，那就是约翰·麦凯恩。
And I was in Russell, Kansas when the Dole campaign came through. And I noticed this. I saw McCain kind of off to one side. He had been with Dole all day. And I went up to talk to him. And he said to me almost apologetically, he said, "You know I wouldn't be here if I thought he was going to win."
当多尔竞选团队经过堪萨斯州拉塞尔时，我正在那里。我注意到了这一点。我看到麦凯恩站在一边。他整天都和多尔在一起。我走过去和他谈话。他几乎带着歉意地对我说，“你知道，如果我认为他会赢，我就不会在这里了。”
And I knew that. He was there because he knew that it was Dole's time of need, and it was time for someone to step up. And this is what's so curious about McCain. I think that he continually-- as I covered this campaign-- I was new to politics when I came into this campaign. I had never written about politics. I found that McCain sort restored my faith in the process again and again.
我知道这一点。他在这里是因为他知道这是多尔需要帮助的时刻，是有人挺身而出的时刻。这就是关于麦凯恩如此好奇的地方。我想他不断地——当我报道这次竞选时——我来到这次竞选时对政治是陌生的。我从未写过关于政治的文章。我发现麦凯恩一次又一次地恢复了我对这个过程的信心。
There was something about his-- how should I put it? It was his willingness to stick his neck out for a losing or an unpopular cause that was so different from most of the people who do what he does for a living-- so different from the ordinary political attitude-- that was refreshing and inspiring.
他的某种气质——我该怎么说呢？是他愿意为一个失败的或不受欢迎的事业而挺身而出，这与大多数靠这个吃饭的人太不同了——与普通的政治态度太不同了——这既清新又鼓舞人心。
Michael Lewis.
迈克尔·刘易斯。
Our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Peter Clowney and Nancy Updike, contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin.
今天的节目由艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人制作，彼得·克劳尼和南希·厄普代克，特约编辑保罗·托夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林参与制作。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Music help from John Connors, Travis Stancil, and Steve Cushing. Thanks to public radio stations WBUR, KPCC, and KQED. If you'd like a copy of this program, it only costs $10. Call us at WBEZ in Chicago. 312-832-3380.
音乐支持来自约翰·康纳斯、特拉维斯·斯坦西尔和史蒂夫·库欣。感谢公共广播电台WBUR、KPCC和KQED。如果你想要一份节目拷贝，只需10美元。请拨打芝加哥WBEZ电台电话。312-832-3380。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持列表]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。